[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec cette
semaine michel onfray bonjour bonjour
merci d'être là on ne vous présente pas
vous êtes philosophe c'est ça votre
métier c'est votre patience et votre
formation mais c'est aussi votre
profession quelque part vous est aussi
chroniqueur de l'actualité c'est un peu
comme ça qu'on vous perçoit avec votre
vision votre analyse vous sortez
d'ailleurs un livre cette semaine chez
albin michel grandeur du petit peuple
380 pages 19 90 voyages donne tout les
prix ce livre c'est votre journal des
gilets jaunes c'est ça non on va en
parler ddd gilet jaune mais vous
raconter ce que vous avez entendu vous
avez compris de ce mouvement c'est ça un
peu comme l'aurait fait victor hugo sur
train de vous flatter ou stevenson dans
ses carnets de voyage
peut-être tocqueville aussi avant parler
des gilets jaunes c'est à dire de ce
livre là plus précisément je serai votre
sentiment sur les mouvements qui
continue de se développer en france de
se développer ou le s'évaluer
progressivement concernant la
manifestation contre la retraite vous
lisez ça comment aujourd'hui c'est quoi
votre interprétation de ce qui s'est
passé encore cette semaine et de ce
qu'il va encore se passer dans les jours
qui viennent parce que j'imagine que ça
va pas se terminer comme ça oui enfin on
se demande toujours comment les choses
vont se passer se dérouler se terminer
on se les poser cette question avec les
gilets jaunes ont cela pose aujourd'hui
avec la question des retraites
le philosophe que j'essaie d'être pose
des questions un peu moins du point de
vue de sirius se dire on devrait penser
autrement la question du temps de
travail la question du travail et la
question du temps de travail c'est
vraiment une question philosophique pour
moi alors évidemment là on est
dans le réel le plus le plus trivial
avec des retraites et puis dans une
espèce de confiscation par la cgt les
gens les gens qui souffrent de tout ça
n'ose pas trop le dire dès qu'on dit
qu'on n'est pris en otages immédiatement
nous dit quoi vous comparer à des gens
de dèche
oui mais c'est quasi un déficit s'est
lui aussi comme une commune comme une
route comme une manifestation de gens
qui sont assez privilégiés qui ont des
systèmes spéciaux de retraite avec des
avec des dates de départ relativement
active par rapport aux autres
correspondent plus forcément à la
réalité économique
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle la réalité
économique pour le coup moi je les
défends s'il faut le dire je défends le
gilet jaune qui sont pour moi les sous
prolétaires je défends également ces
gens là qui pour le coup ce sont les
prolétaires mais qui sont organisées
avec des syndicats avec des partis avec
eux des journaux avec des
représentations à l'assemblée nationale
ou au sénat et c'est pas vraiment le
même monde et je pense que les premiers
le sous prolétariat dispose de sa force
de travail un point c'est tout et encore
une force de travail que qu'on n'emploie
pas ou qu'on exploite parfois alors que
de fait vous avez raison il ya des
régimes divers et multiples qui
supposerait moins qu'on aille mettre le
nez dans le cambouis en disant allez sur
ce cas là avec et c'est vraiment trop
con créant dire alors ici les
contrôleurs aériens
ici les roulants après les gens qui
s'occupent à la sncf n'ont pas de deux
des trains mais du contrôle et du doseur
de lier rares et puis il ya les danseurs
de l'opéra appui à tous ces gens là la
police la gendarmerie l'armée fab ont je
pense qu'on devrait pouvoir vraiment
pensé le travail ça s'est fait à une
époque où il y avait des gens comme
michel foucault qui travaille avec la
cfdt edmond maire où on se disait mais
finalement il ya aujourd'hui des gens
comme dominique méda qui ont aussi pensé
ces questions dans dix ans mais est ce
qu'on pourrait pas déjà commencé par
penser le problème là quand il ya autant
de travail qui a autant de chômeurs qui
a autant de gens qui sont dans la
demande d'emploi qu'il ya autant de gens
bien d'avoir 61 ans mais qui dans cette
catégorie d'âge ne travaillent pas
autant de gens qui se font arrêter
autant de gens qui sont dans la logique
comme on dit aujourd'hui du burn out
est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas à repenser
le travail avec ceux qui ont envie de
travailler avec ceux qui ne veulent pas
travailler
moi je ne suis pas pour le revenu
universel moi j'ai un travail vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure qui est
formidable je me mets le matin mon
bureau je travaille 10 heures par jour
avec un vrai bonheur mais quand je vais
faire mes courses et que je vois la
caissière je me dis je comprends très
bien qu'elle ait pas envie de travailler
forcément beaucoup et d'imaginer qu'il y
aurait un sens du travail bien fait
michel devraient tous
vous dites là plaidé pour une réforme
des systèmes de retraite je suis
d'accord le système de réformes qu'on a
proposé c'est d'ailleurs un système qui
a été inventé au départ par la gauche
comme je vous faut relire george aurait
donc je suis pour la réforme parce que
je pense qu'effectivement ça ne peut pas
fonctionner comme ça fonctionne à
l'individualisation est présent sauf des
conditions personnelles etc
oui parce qu'effectivement il ya des
gens qui aiment travailler des gens qui
n'aiment pas des gens qui ont envie des
gens qui n'ont pas envie des métiers qui
sont épanouissant puis des métiers qui
ne le sont pas c'était ça la réforme
alors compte tenu en mairie mars comment
se fait-il que cette pédagogie là ne
soit pas passé alors ne me faites pas
dire ce que je n'ai pas dit c'est à dire
que si je pense effectivement qu'il
faudrait faire une réforme qui
supposerait qu'on pense véritablement la
question du travail
je ne suis pas d'accord avec ce que
propose m'a conquis et d'anti qui lui
est dans une logique de défense de ce
qu'on appelle l'état profond des
intérêts de l'état profond alors 10 à
une époque que trump utilise cette
expression d'état profond c'est une
expression d'extrême droite macron vient
de l'utiliser lui-même
donc il y a quand même effectivement des
directives de bruxelles qui oblige à
cette réforme on voit bien que ce n'est
pas la france qui intéresse macron mais
c'est pas le travail français où le
travailleur français ne s'est pas la
classe ouvrière française qui se sont
pas les cheminots français on lui a dit
viens une feuille de route et cette
feuille de route c'est effectivement de
taper dans le dur de faire de telle
sorte que ni plus de solidarité et que
finalement effectivement on part c'est
lise et qu'il n'y ait plus que des
individus
ça c'est la grande logique du
libéralisme parce qu'au bout du compte
ce qu'il nous faut c'est pas un citoyen
on n'en veut plus du citoyen c'est un
consommateur
alors là on en vit au coeur à d'autres
de raisonnement lorsque vous dites
effectivement le gouvernement français
obéit aux injonctions de maastricht mais
des injonctions de maastricht initiale
en feraient elles sont elles ont été
édictées elles ont été pensés par les
différents gouvernements européens et
elles sont contrôlés tous les jours par
les opinions publiques européennes
non mais j'entends bien mais simplement
dans l'urne c'est pas un diktat mais
bien sûr que si puisqu'on a renoncé à
notre souveraineté nationale vous savez
très bien qu'il y avait bien vu qu'on ne
respecte pas on est en déficit
budgétaire en permanence afin ce qu'on
ne respecte pas c'est la volonté
populaire en 2005 quand le peuple a dit
que ça nous qu'il n'en voulait plus ah
bah non mais vous faites un oui comme ça
de madame encore le problème n'était pas
là alors qu'il est là c'est à dire que
tout le monde défend l'europe
tout le monde connaît pas de gens qui
sont anti européen cette idée de dire il
ya les européens puis elles sont ceux
qui ne sont pas européens mais tout le
monde est européen simplement quelle
heure
peut-on donc une europe des nations dans
laquelle on verrait on verrait du côté
jusqu'à du côté du haut du meilleur de
ce qui se fait de mieux s'intéresserait
tout le monde
pourquoi est-ce que c'est à linverse
toujours les mêmes qui payent les
pauvres les modestes et c est pourquoi
ce sont toujours les mêmes qui échappent
soit à l'impôt soit aux ponctions qu'il
pourrait qu'ils pourraient connaître
parce que on pourra voir qu'il ya un
gouvernement plus équitable ou un
gouvernement une politique plus
équitable ou moins cynique ce sont
toujours les plus pauvres qui paye quand
on augmente le prix de l'essence et du
gasoil
on sait très bien que ce sont les plus
modestes on va taxer sont pas les gens
qui sont dans les paradis fiscaux se
sont pas les gens qui fraudent etc
on voit bien que s'il y avait les deux
peut-être que les gens accepteraient de
dire les plus modestes de dire on veut
bien mettre la main au porte-monnaie
nous aussi mais pourquoi est-ce que
d'autres je ne parle même pas de carlos
ghosn mais pourquoi est ce que d'autres
peuvent avoir autant d'argent et de
n'être pas inquiété pourquoi est-ce que
des multinationales peuvent très bien ne
jamais payer d'impôts etc
enfin tout toutes choses qui font que
s'il y avait vraiment un désir de
d'équité les français seraient
probablement plus à même de devenir
qu'il consente à cette réforme si elle
ferait que je vais pas faire de
polémique c'est pas mon rôle
mon rôle est plutôt de de vous
interroger mais est ce que vous n'avez
pas aujourd'hui conscience parfois de
tordre un peu l'effet pour qu'il réponde
et pour qu'ils appuient votre
raisonnement lesquelles par exemple quel
sur la socialisation sur la
libéralisation du système
est ce que vous avez vraiment le
sentiment que nous sommes dans des pays
ultra libéraux ou l'idea non je dirais
pas ça comme ça parce que je vis est
quelque chose de paradoxal dans le
libéralisme européen c'est que moi je
serais un libéral c'est le libéralisme
était vraiment ce qu'il était au xviiie
siècle
oui mais c'est pas le cas c'est pas le
cas c'est l'état qui impose le
libéralisme c'est sidérant vous avez 55
% des dépenses de libéraliser la dépense
publique là mais c'est un bon gars dans
un pays socialiste
non je ne peux pas dans la répartition
de pleinement dans le prélèvement
monsieur non non non moi je pense que le
libéralisme
on en a que des inconvénients et pas les
avantages je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose de paradoxal il faut repenser
d'ailleurs le libéralisme en évitant de
penser que ça relèverait de la
philosophie du xviiie ou encore du 19e
siècle non pas du tout on a passé le 20e
siècle et on est dans un libéralisme
d'état c'est un c'est un paradoxe est un
oxymore
d'une certaine manière parce que le
libéralisme voudrait faire au maximum
l'économie de l'état en pensant qu'une
espèce de main invisible et on voit bien
que c'est pas du tout de même invisible
que ce que c'est la main est justement
du fameuse état profond qui lui fait la
loi dans le sens de la disparition des
souverainetés de la disparition des
nations pour fabriquer une europe qui
serait une espèce de courroie de
transmission pour un grand gouvernement
planétaire qui serait très saint
simoniens ces gouvernements des gens
intelligents des gens qui savent avec
des citoyens dont on n'aurait pas besoin
de demander l'avis du monde
oui c'est ça oui voilà on va revenir à
grandeur du petit peuple parce que c'est
de lui dont il est question
le mouvement 1 on envoie vous en parlez
bien tourner est en train de bien sûr
mais sur les retraites il y avait une
revendication précise
est-ce que vous avez compris quelle
était la revendication haut niveau au
moment des gilets jaunes
il ya une revendication de dignité au
moment des ronds-points je dirais
abandonnés ou jeudi s'est noyé hier
moments durs au point il ya un moment
des champs elysées il ya un moment de
l'agglo triomphe et c'est tout au départ
ce sont juste des gens qui disent si
vous augmentez le prix du carburant nous
on va pas pouvoir donc sont pas des gens
qui disent on veut réformer la
constitution veut ceci on veut cela ils
disent juste on n'en peut plus on ne
peut pas on a on a plus de dignité on a
on ne peut pas acheter de jouer à nos
enfants souvenez vous on était un peu
avant noël des gens disaient mais moi je
suis chez mes parents parce que je ne
peux pas me payer un loyer alors que je
travaille je travaille et je dors dans
ma voiture et a donc dès le départ
c'était une revendication de dignité
mais vous avez dit on n'a pas écouté ces
gens là on ne pas aller les voir mais
comment vouliez vous les écoutez puisque
personne ne prenait la parole et
personne n'était légitime pour
l'apprendre y en un qui est légitime
pour prendre la parole sur ce sujet là
ça s'appelle un président de la
république parce qu'il est investi de la
souveraineté nationale c'est à dire que
quand il en avait au niveau des gilet
jaune n est pas qu on en cherchait il
faut les médias les ont créés quelques
parties ya le sait pas imaginer qu'il ya
un tremblement de terre terrible qui
coupent paris en deux et qui était il y
aura pas quelqu'un pour parler au nom du
tremblement de terre et le chef de
l'état prendrait des raids de prendre
aider
décision donc quand on voit ce qui se
passe n'a qu'à ouvrir sa télévision pour
regarder ce qui se passe ou demander à
ces renseignements généraux à partir de
ce moment là le chef de l'état doit
pouvoir dire j'entends ce qui se passe
et je vais faire quelque chose de l'or
il s'agit pas forcément de rencontrer
des gens pour quoi faire
il faudrait dire ah mais ça c'est
monsieur gilet jaune ou madame gilet
jaune c'est un monsieur gilet jaune
qu'on pourrait voir la télévision qu'on
pourrait invité sur les plateaux avec
laquelle on pourrait discuter non vous
avez juste on a créé quelques
représentants la désillusion
enfin ils se sont créé le maire des
médians à briquet de projets désireux de
rodrigues est seulement maxime unique
absolument mais moi j'attendais d'un
président mais auriez choisi moi oui non
moi j étais médias ambages médiane au
moins médias sûrement pas mais non mais
je me dis m'imaginais le général de
gaulle à la position dans la position de
la somme à l'époque était différent il y
avait ma les résonances il y en a mais
même aujourd'hui et de relever les
réseaux sociaux ça marche aussi
le diamant de nous vous entendez ce que
le peuple vous dit drôle entendait quand
il se passe mai 68 qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est très difficile non mais
choisir des ce que le nez 68 surgit le
général de gaulle se dit que se
passe-t-il dépôt mais non pas du tout
pas du tout le monde dit aujourd'hui
baden baden à la la il a mis 48 heures
pour comprendre ya des gens qui ont
toujours pas compris aujourd'hui
cinquante ans après donc voilà quelqu'un
qui dit effectivement c'est un s'est
amusé il vient d'écrire je finis un
livre sur le mythe errant de gaulle
c'est très intéressant de voir la
réaction de de gaulle à ce moment-là il
rend des avis et il discute avec malraux
ils voient que c'est une question de
civilisation et il dit je porte ma
réponse est la réponse est la
participation
la droite détruit tout ça pour faire de
telle sorte d'alliance mais il règle le
problème avec un deal avec la cgt n'en
ai d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs pompidou
qui règle un problème non
avec femmes l'augmentation faramineuse
vous avez le pouvoir d'achat avec un
vous avez raison car à quoi il faut des
accords de grenelle
d'accord comme ça à coke non parce que à
quoi il faut ajouter le fait que de
gaulle avait compris qu'il y avait un
problème de civilisation civilisation de
2,6 à sion qu'il appelait matériel oui
il est très intéressant de lille avait
aussi compris qu'il n'était pas capable
lui même de la gérer vous êtes vous êtes
un juge et je ne crois pas et je pense
que macro aurait très bien pu dire
j'écoute j'entends et j'ai pas besoin de
rencontrer des gens pour savoir que ces
gens me demandent la dignité
simplement il ne pas les rencontrer
parce qu'il n'a pas envie de donner de
la dignité à ces gens là ils s'en
moquent complètement il disait on a le
village on disait on a le choix entre la
fin du monde est là et
et la fin du mois c'est gilet jaune qui
ont dit ça ce sont les communicants de
maquereaux ces communes est candidat
commission de macron il attend lyon
opposé
c'est la fin du monde formidable c'est
des trucs pour les journalistes ça oui
c'est à dire que vous n'avez pas faire
dix prochaines années
oui ça c'est le truc vous savez très
bien que le soir ça va être pris et
qu'après trois mois plus tard on ne
retiendra que ça j'ai des gens qui ont
dit mais c'est pas contradictoire fin du
monde et fin d'année moitié passe
comment ça vous plaît mais c'était une
façon de dire ces gens là sont des
paysans dp corps des péquenots dans
n'ont rien à faire de la planète du
réchauffement climatique c'est un
prétexte de réchauffement climatique
dans ces cas là ce sont des gens qui
n'ont rien compris à la nature alors
qu'ils vivent tous la plupart du temps
dans le dans un milieu rural et et les
autres disaient mais c'est pas ça notre
problème c'est pas la fin de la fin du
monde on veut même bien que ce soit
aussi notre problème si vous le
souhaitez mais c'est pour nous c'est la
fin du mois c'est à dire qu'on n'arrive
pas à joindre les deux bouts
un président de la république qui donc
il a signé un chèque il a fait ce qui
est une secte une humiliation terrible
pour mais vous rendez vous des droits au
sujet des gens vous demandent de la
dignité vous leur donnez de l'argent
fait ça avec les prostituées
si vous arrivez avec votre valise de
billets vous dites je t'achète voilà et
non fais pas ça si c'est ajouter de
l'indignité à l'indignité avait un
besoin de pouvoir d'achat il y avait
comme il ya toujours un besoin de
restauration de la dignité du petit
peuple qui est digne qui demandait de la
dignité de la dignité ça fait plus rien
dire à personne
il m'a très digne feu emmanuel macron
dans son comportement dans sa vie dans
ce qu'il a dit non ce qu'il a fait et ça
ira ça fait deux ans qu'il est au
pouvoir
l'indignité est souvent au rendez vous
voilà des gens qui demandaient de la
dignité de la considération c'est facile
ce serait facile par le conditionnel
parce que ça ne concerne pas mais pour
un chef d'état qui serait digne de ce
nom et bien qu'ils seraient à chef
d'état digne de ce nom de dire j'entends
je vais au devant de sa et la dignité
je vais vous la donner et ça va être
ceci cela puis à son bras il arrive avec
un catalogue de changements sociaux de
changement métaphysique de changement
politique de changement républicain est
pas une valise de billets on revient
dans quarante secondes pour poursuivre
cet entretien on est dans la grande
intérieure
[Musique]
michel offrait un quart de seconde sur
la réaction que vous avez au mouvement
d'elie jaune à votre lecture à votre
analyse et vous étiez en train de dire
que la réponse de du président de la
république n'a pas été à la hauteur de
ce que vous avez cru entendre dans la
rue le peuple de france dans son
histoire a toujours été régicide sens
sans pouvoir formaliser les vraies
raisons toujours un je suis pas d'accord
non pas le peuple
la représentation nationale avec l
assemblée nationale a été régicide et ne
l'a pas été non plus massivement quand
vous regardez le nombre de gens qui ont
voté pour la peine de mort qui ont voté
la mort de louis saez ceux qui ont voté
la peine de mort mais en dix ans en même
temps on ne l'exécutera pas cette peine
il faut que ce soit symbolique
ceux qui ont voté contre le les gens qui
étaient dans la représentation nationale
n'ont pas massivement voté pour la mort
du roi
maintenant je pense que le peuple le
petit peuple n'avait pas envie d'amour
du roi les gens qui les jacks rôle et
d'olivier ce qu'on appelait ensuite les
enragés qui disait mais on veut du pain
pour nous enfants vos du lait on veut
d'eux de la chandelle pour voir c'est ce
que je veux dire c'est raymond
cristallisation du mouvement contre le
président de la république est un peu le
poids de france ed oui mais c est lui
qui a joué ce jeu là souvenez-vous ce
monsieur qui nous dit dans dans
l'opposition il ya une place vacante et
celle du roi qui a été décapité
on entend ça on entend le personnage qui
nous dit même ma président sera
jupitérienne nantes ans à un personnage
qui nous dit ma parole sera rare on
entend ça un personnage qui se fait
photographier avec trois volumes de la
pléiade sur son bureau
parmi les trois volumes de la pléiade
outre gide et stendhal
il y a le général de gaulle donc
quelqu'un qui annonce jupiters le
général de gaulle et qui au bout du
compte avec la sphère benalla se montre
globalement comme tous les autres ils
font de la politique politicienne
il a perdu son crédit mais geoffrey
c'est aussi un président qui s'est fait
élire après une campagne relativement
longue et qui s'est fait élire ou arrivé
au premier tour puis au deuxième tour et
qui est qu'ils étaient installés par la
constitution pour rien pour pour
gouverner pendant cinq ans une élection
dont laquelle la propagande n'a pas joué
un rôle mince ou le savez très bien dans
laquelle on a distribué un programme
notamment
un nombre de gens en retraite qui ne
sont pas allés voter des gens qui vont
voter n'importe quoi alors qu'elle jean
claude et condé c'est le sait le système
même de la démocratie représentative
non en cause c'est la façon qu'ont les
élus aujourd'hui de prendre la
démocratie en otage nous sommes sortis
de la démocratie nous sommes en poste
démocratie le général de gaulle prenait
à témoin le peuple
il disait je demande référendum vous
voulez vous ne voulez pas élection vous
voulez vous ne voulez pas quand
mitterrand invente la cohabitation il
invente effectivement la confiscation du
pouvoir par les élites c'est à dire que
quand on perd les élections législatives
on s'en va on se dit bah je remets mon
mandat en cause et puis il ya pas de
cohabitation ça n'est pas pensable cette
espèce de caractère bicéphale de la
constitution du général de gaulle
l'avait exclu dans une conférence de
presse qu qu'après vous avez chirac qui
fait exactement la même chose
giscard savez bien quand il a failli
perdre relief quand il a pu penser qu'il
aurait pu perdre les élections
législatives avaient pensé qu'il
resterait président le lui dit il se
retirerait à versailles c'est tout dire
quand même le général de gaulle dit vous
ne voulait plus de moi je m'en vais tous
ces gens là quand on leur dit on ne veut
plus de vous ils disent je reste
mitterrand reste giscard rester chirac à
rester est resté votre tête c'est la
fracture entre le pss ce que vous
appelez le pape
et puis les élites mais mon problème
c'est que la démocratie ça que vous
décrivez là je sais qu'on sait que la
république n'est plus là je vous dis
quand cotte vous êtes un chef de l'état
vous avez compris que vous n'êtes pas
vous n'étiez pas oui mais michel fraisse
qu'est-ce que vous déclarez décrété
comme le petit peuple et sa grandeur
est-ce que c'est homogène n'est pas
homogène au niveau sociologique mais je
soutiens a dit qu'il l'était vous avez
raison ce ne l'est pas il est divers
multiples lydia dans le peuple de la
populace il y a de la foule et un peu de
calme au caire il ya un peu de petite
bourgeoisie bien sûr quelques
intellectuels artistes comédiens qui
sont arrivés sur le chemin neuf mois
plus tard
à oui mais c'est aussi ça le problème
c'est qu'on me dit j'ai un gilet jaune
je suis un gilet jaune
c'est un peu ça qui fait aussi la
difficulté de ceux de ce mouvement là
mais vous avez raison il n'ya pas
d'homogénéité mais ceci dit il ya une
homogénéité dans la demande de dignité
vous savez très bien moi je mon village
natal champs bois ou que des événements
ou des voisins vous savez bien vous
habitez l'orne aussi où vous avez habité
et bien mon village natal s'est effondré
je viens de fêter mes soixante et un ans
le village que j'ai connu avec son école
avec sa poste avec ses commerçants avec
sa vitalité avec son autonomie on
pouvait passer sa vie dans ce village
sans jamais sortir de ce village vous
pouvez y naître on pouvait y mourir
on se faisait fabriquer son cercueil sur
place on avait le prêtre qui était là et
c'est tout ça s'est effondrée et les
gens disent mais on veut bien payer des
impôts on en paie on paie des impôts
directs on paie des impôts indirects
quand on fait notre connaissance on fait
toujours on peut toujours aux impôts
y a plus d'école mais enfin bien que
d'école ça s'est effondré bien sûr mais
est ce que c'était est-ce que c'était
des structures porteuses de bonheur
écoutez quand vous étiez dans une école
où on apprenait à lire écrire à compter
à penser et xavier 15 ans il n'y a
qu'une envie c'était de partir a fait
4-2 tazi mais au moins quand vous
partiez vous saviez dire écrire compter
penser c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
l'école est terminée et on a fait des
grandes écoles dans lesquelles les
gamins sont perdus dans lesquelles les
pommes pourries contaminent la totalité
du panier parce que vous avez deux ou
trois qui effectivement sont des petites
frappes et on voit bien que quand dans
un village ça sera quand même pas
seulement ce livre et vous en avez fait
quoi une cinquante soixante autres à
vous êtes très productif plus d'une
centaine d'une centaine
quand on vous lit on a quand même
l'impression que que vous faîtes quelque
part vous regrettez quelque part
l'invasion du progrès technologique qui
ont précédé l'invasion de la sphère
économique de la sphère financière
oui voilà et et que vous regrettez
l'évolution que tout ça progresse non
non quand même eu des progrès oui au
cours des 50 dernières années je ne le
nie pas je ne le nie pas il semble et ce
progrès a profité à tout le monde ne
sait pas forcément mais vous savez le
progrès c'est pas l'espérance de vie est
là quasiment profiter à tout le monde ça
des progrès de la santé ils ont profité
ça dépend dans quel état vous
zone des 15 20 ans oui non mais vous
dire s'il s'agit de dire on peut vivre
maintenant plus facilement jusqu'à 100
ans oui d'accord mais dans quel état
entre 70 et 100 ou 1000 1 398 laissé
entendre c'est que tout ça a été
confisqué à par une élite
oui ça ça oui vous devez c'est à dire
que vous avez vous avez dit deux choses
dont une part est vrai effectivement il
ya une évolution technologique je ne
suis pas contre je dis simplement que
c'était évolutions technologiques pour
une boucle pour tout dire la révolution
numérique
elle est au service du fameux état
profond et on voit très bien tout au
départ quand on vous a dit vous aurez
des ordinateurs vous verrez comme ce
sera formidable pour vous et je me
souvient jacques attali nous disant le
matin notre avion qui aurait été en
retard on nous aurait dit sur notre
téléphone portable que finalement il y
avait refermé le nom mais c'est des
clichés dans la main quelques de
nathalie à la main et qui nous disaient
mais ce sera tellement sur la mi temps
mais ça me parliez saint henri sert aux
noms n'ont pas forcément ça ne ça sert
aujourd'hui cette technologie à nous
fliquer à nous embêter à nous ennuyer à
savoir ce qu'on fait pour pouvoir
communiquer moi comme ma campagne a eu
un cancer on a tout de suite reçu
immédiatement sur nos téléphones
respectifs des de la publicité pour les
assurances obsèques pour les pompes
funèbres générales
non mais je veux dire qu'ils
connaissaient rien dire qu'on est très
impliqué avec un médecin une femme noire
des grandes innovations technologiques
elles ont profité au plus grand nombre
braudel d'ailleurs une a décrit sa très
bien une seule machine à vapeur saha
profite à tout le monde
l'électricité ça a profité à tout le
monde l'internet ça profite à tout le
monde sait ce que ça dépend ce que
séparés pour les élites ça dépend ce que
vous appelez profiter je reprends de
soyons concret soyez empirique ce
village dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure en bois 500 habitants fracture
numérique total c'est à dire que moi
quand je parlerai ben oui mais alors y'a
pas de problème si vous êtes en 4g ou
1,5 g dans les meilleurs quartiers de
paris
mais si vous êtes dans ce village moi
quand j'y suis une semaine je n'ai pas
de message suggère de prendre ma voiture
sortir du village trouver une éminence
et puis à ce moment là les messages
arrivent que je redescends chez moi et
c'est donc quand on nous dit internet
c'est pour tout le monde nous on sait
très bien que c'est faux
le haut débit internet la couverture
téléphonique etc
ça n'existe pas et quand macron a dit
votez pour moi dans deux ans il y aura
plus une seule zone blanche sur le
territoire national deux ans plus tard
il ya toujours ces zones blanches et ça
ne marche toujours pas donc non le
progrès technique s'est il est fait par
quelques-uns pour
quelques uns et les autres sont à la
traîne alors je reviens à ma mère à 85
en ciel veut prendre le train par
exemple aujourd'hui mais comment voulez
vous qu'elle puisse aller sur son
ordinateur pour réserver son train pour
choisir etc
il ya plein de gens qui sont exclues de
tout s'arrête c'est vrai c'est vrai que
j'ai une fracture tout ce qui est
attendu à une égalité et qui accroît les
fractures son désaccord
c'est vrai mais d'une façon générale je
reviens à votre oeuvre je reviens à ce
que vous avez écrit je reviens aussi par
exemple à tout ce que vous avez fait sur
l'histoire des religions qui m'a
passionné que vous avez fait dans des
universités populaires en normandie
la dimension économique de tout ça est
souvent absent de votre raisonnement
même dans même dans vos analyses
actuelles une grande entreprise
aujourd'hui qui est créatrice de
richesses finalement vous avez tendance
à dire qu'elle appartient à des fonds de
pension c'est à dire qu'elles sont
l'objet d'un complot des grands
financiers vos esprits texans une grande
entreprise ça appartient à ses clients
de son personnel et a sauvé ses
consommateurs oui donc à tout le monde
mais bien le chef d'entreprise il
travaille pour pour tous où ai-je écrit
le contraire de ça ici parce que les
élites d'à côté le pape de nantes passe
à un autre moment
maintenant j'essaie vite vous mettez
vous mettez des élites économiques et
financières oui mais c'est quoi
l'économie s'est pas seulement les
patrons du cac 40 s'est pas seulement
les fonds de pension l'économie ce sont
les artisans les commerçants les petits
mais il faudra donc ce sont les
retraites j'entends bien mais je dis là
on parle d'un autre sujet vous étiez en
train de me dire qu'il y avait pas
d'économie chez moi mais il n'ya que de
l'économie non mais parce que je parle
de ceux dont l'économie libérale ne
parle pas j'ai les fameux plombier
polonais si vous voulez les boulangers
dans l'est dans les villages les gens
qui qui sont obligés de se déplacer tout
ça c'est de l'économie on sait très bien
l'effondrement de l'agglo de la société
villageoise qui était une convivialité
c'est de l'économie et moi j'ai toujours
pensé à peu
bolis d'ailleurs que la tendance devait
suivre c'est pas l'économie qui fait la
loi c'est la loi qui devrait faire
l'économie
et on sait très bien aujourd'hui qu'on
nous dit c'est pas possible le
libéralisme à l'horizon indépassable
comme chez les intellectuels d'origine
bien sûr exactement comme le marxisme
exactement qui ça n'a pas été conçu par
carl barks à ça n'a pas été conçu par un
a été conçu par franck magry non mais je
lis la saison prague et si vous dire de
les lire vous les connaissez vous prenez
smith vous prenez tous les to les
libéraux qui ont théorisé qu'est ce qui
existait mais bon ça c'est conçu à 6 et
une c'est une mission que si c'est une
idéologie qui procède du déisme du
xviiie siècle
mason maçonnique la plupart du temps sur
cette idée qu'il y aurait une main
invisible qui parlons en
on ne sait pas une idée de l'art je vous
dise en est le marché avec est ce qu'on
appelle une image s'est assis à ses
côtés de nos magazines laisser faire et
finalement laisser faire laisser passer
la main de dieu y mettra bon ordre
c'est tout ça s'appelle une idéologie et
on voit bien que quand on leur fait
croire en dieu pour qu'il ait une main
moi je n'y crois pas je pense pas qu'ils
aient la main de dieu et je pense que
laisser faire laisser passer c'est
laisser faire le chaos s'est pas laissée
faire l'ordre du monde qui serait de
l'ordre libéral un ordre des listes
issues de la franc maçonnerie du xviiie
siècle très éclairé c'était très éclairé
sauf que c'était une idéologie c'est
toujours une idéologie vous le savez
bien parce que bourdieu avait théorisé
les deux mains vous savez ce qu'on donne
d'un côté ce qu'on reprend de l'autre
etc
aujourd'hui on dit il faut pas que ça
coûte l'école ne doit pas coûter on
ferme les écoles dans les campagnes etc
d'accord de les fabriquer une
délinquance qui va vous coûter en
jugeant magistrats en prison en police
etc
voilà vous faites des économies ici et
puis là vous allez être obligé de faire
des dépenses parce que vous aurez fait
des économies ici l'économie c'est aussi
ça c'est une espèce de perspectives
assez lointaine qui nous permet de dire
si nous désinvesti sont ici nous
réinvestirons ailleurs mais dans le mal
si on apprend plus à lire à écrire à
compter à penser parce qu'on veut huit
avoir des enseignants mal formés etc
on va fabriquer des illettrés si la
santé vous le savez bien j'entendais
hier dans un taxi quelque chose de
terrible on parlait d'un médicament pour
soigner je ne sais quelle maladie il
était dans un taxi j'entendais pas très
bien on a dit ça va pouvoir être mis sur
le marché parce qu'effectivement ça
coûtait trop cher ça ne pouvait pas être
remboursés seuls quelques-uns vous
rendez compte
quand macron décide d'envoyer quelques
bombes sur la syrie juste pour pouvoir
dire qu'il a envoyé des bombes
on a
argent pour ça l'économie elle est
toujours problématique jamais pour
bombarder les pays musulmans sur la
planète ou poursuivre l'impérialisme
américain quand il s'agit de dire
allons-y investissons dans la santé des
français et permettons gens modestes de
pouvoir être guéri sauver ou soigner là
ce moment là il ya plus d'argent il faut
faire de l'économique en tunisie juste
que c'est une idéologie
oui michel onfray je m'en voudrais de ne
pas pas parler en 30 secondes et vous
interroger sur sur un des problèmes qui
préoccupent notamment les nouvelles
générations qui est la transition
écologique et la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
vous êtes très prononcé des mots
terribles contre greta feinberg disant
que c'était un pur produit marketing non
d'abord je vous remercie de dire ça
parce que maintenant j'ai fait un texte
de 15 mille signes vous vous savez ce
que ça fait casting c'est un gros oui
papier oui sur ce gros papillon n'a
repris deux ou trois choses notamment
des moments voltairien français où je me
dis qu'elle un visage de cyborg jeudi
qu'elles envisageaient de si beaux
immédiatement on dit on ferait des tests
les autistes et j'ai des associations
d'autistes contre moi et c'est à le fond
de mon papier c'est pourquoi c'est
pourquoi je vous en remercie c'est nike
et ea et donc voilà vous avez dit ça
mais bien sûr mais c'est sam harris a
une utilité le marketing ça va permettre
de nous on est d'accord
bon on est d'accord mais si on est
d'accord tous les actifs quand même dans
votre esprit oui bob d'un nouveau raté
dans le mien oui c'est à dire jeudi mail
vous prenez en vous confisquer du talent
non pas ce ton entourage a dit alors ah
c'est pas la même chose donc kiki et son
entourage
après on dit si vous posez cette
question là vous êtes complotistes je
dis simplement que le capitalisme moi je
ne suis pas marxiste je n'ai jamais été
je n'ai jamais pensé comme marx que le
capitalisme a vu une date de naissance
ce qui rendrait possible une date de
décès il suffit juste d'avoir la
volaille c'est tromper là dessus je suis
entièrement de la camdiac du capitalisme
dès qu'il ya de l'humain de l'homme dès
que vous regardez aujourd'hui sauvé ta
peau d'archéologie et que vous faites de
l'archéologie préhistorique vous avez
des tombes dans lesquelles vous voyez
que les femmes ou les hommes sont
enterrés avec des jolies des jolis
bijoux qui sont d'aider que des
coquillages rares et les coquillages
sont rochon cher parce qu'ils sont rares
et donc la rareté fait la valeur et donc
l'idée que la rareté face la valeur
c'est le début du capitalisme donc il ya
un capitalisme préhistorique et puis
après je vais pas vous faire un cours
vous savez ça mieux que moi mais je dire
qu'il ya déjà eu des capitalismes
égyptien sumériens babyloniens illégal
il a fallu un capitalisme pour
construire les pyramides et c'est
qu'après vous avez la grèce 2 0 mais un
capitalisme européen le nôtre maintenant
et dans ce capitalisme européen des
moments aussi qui ont été des
capitalismes féodaux des capitales de la
rené surface et au dos de la renaissance
et à un capitalisme industriel et nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans le capitalisme
vert je dis juste qu'un certain nombre
de gens ceux qui sont avec red hat
hennebert nous ont dit il va falloir
faire consommer maintenant il faut que
les gens consomment donc si on veut leur
faire vendre à leur faire acheter des
voitures de l'électricité ou je sais pas
quoi il faut enveloppé tout ça d'un
discours écologique
je dis simplement que ce n'est pas
contre non je voudrais juste qu'on en
dise par exemple si l'écologie
intéressait vraiment les gens on ouvrait
savoir que par exemple la voiture
électrique ne peut fonctionner que s'il
ya des centrales nucléaires s'il ya des
désaccords nous fera savoir par exemple
ferai savoir que ces fameuses éoliennes
dont on nous dit qu'elle produise des
énergies beaucoup plus cher et des
tonnes de béton pour mesurer les
installer sont une pollution visuelle
avec la qualité c'est pas les
contradictions s'étoffer si vraiment on
était soucieux d'écologie et de deux
clubs défense de la planète y aurait pas
de voiture électrique parce que les
composants de métaux rares face à celle
là le problème c'est que il faut qu'on
arrête de nous dire que pour être
écologiste il faut polluer pourvu que ce
soit avec un moteur donc il faut être
cohérent et ça ne faut pas et faut pas
développer ses trois tirs voilà il faut
pas nous dire de l'écologie la
transition climatique vous ne pouvez pas
être contre sinon est un complot
nationale a et s'est juste dit on a
juste envie de vous faire acheter une
voiture
on a juste envie de vous faire consommer
d'électricité on a juste envie de faire
rouler en trottinette mais parce qu'il
faut que vous puissiez acheter ces
choses là et quand vous rendre sa
désirable jeu c'est un produit marketing
le capitalisme est cette jeune fille
c'est le ségala si vous voulez de du du
marketing du capitalisme veulent encore
une formule qui lui vole à reprocher à
un mot simplement pour terminer
c'était mieux avant non bon je peux pas
tout vous aimez pas non mais on a la
pression quand même de temps en temps du
com et faisait sûrement dit dans notre
entretien
vous avez l'impression vous donnez
l'impression et j'aimerais obligé dire
ce que je dis et pas ce que vous pensez
vous savez la communication c'est un
émetteur et un léger par exemple
j'estime que mon père qui était ouvrier
agricole a écrit a appris à lire à
écrire à compter à penser à l'école je
pense que c'était mieux l'école à
l'époque où la république je veux ni un
soda voilà je pense effectivement que
les gens qui mouraient à 40 ans étaient
moins bien que les gens qui ont une
espérance de vie plus grande j'ajoute
que cette espérance de vie fait la
quantité de la vie ce qui n'est pas la
qualité de la vie et que nous pouvons
avoir d'autres critères de jugement donc
je suis plus subtil que ce qu'on veut
bien croire
en disant aux frais est un passéiste il
pensait que dans le temps c'était mieux
mais chez visa ou merci mille fois on
prend rendez-vous pour reparler de
l'ergonomie dans l'histoire est
notamment des religions ou d'effort
géopolitique avec plaisir parce que vous
reconnaissez que c'est un peu absent de
votre votre préoccupation non je pense
michel onfray en es-tu rt france et la
grande interview on la retrouve en
rediffusion en replay et puis sur le
site internet surtout arte france - tv
[Musique]